Bà chứ nó nỉnh buồn thì kè,
thì chú vi này bốn thì ta sẽ suy ở được là
hài ở đổ hài ở đổ đổ đổ đổ đổ đổ đổ đổ đổ
thì thì bạn hài, tất cả cái em sẽ có đổ đổ đổ đổ đổ đổ đổ
và hát và một tổ đổ thì
thì có khu chỗ công thức là về của chúng ta bằng P
nhìn ai đổ bình phương, nhìn về hát
là bạn nó một phần từ P
đoàn về kèm thấy đợt, đợt, đợt, bê nó chỉ có xong với bài thân chân nào đúng
thì có nhiều sao càng trọc xe gì ở vậy?
thì xe nó có ăn gì đấy
Hài P
Mình xong gì mà em chọn xe vậy
dụ khi thấy của thống mất là em tình bán dầm như thế nào đó thì không dọ luôn ý
Chú vi hông bốn thì đúng dân dân dân dân dân dân dân hát rồi
nhưng mà tại sao em chọn xe vậy
thì cho các bạn thì thì thấy cũng không tình bán ở về kèm xanh của nhiều của này đó